I got three things. You got content, we got backlinks, and we have age of domain.
We're going to show you how to find all those things, how to assess all those things,
how to audit all those things, how to do all those things.
Those are the things that's the 80-20 principle.
That's the 20 percent of things that give you 80 percent of the results.
So all these other things that we're going to teach you, they do matter.
OK, and we're going to do them.
We're going to make sure we do them correctly.
But remember, fundamentally, if we can do those things better than everybody else
that we can control, because we can't control the age,
we can do those other two better than everybody else, we will win the game.
And especially if we're going against competition, that is not that great.